[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua phillips milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists the less we consume
the less waste we produce amen but
that's only one way that minimalism
helps the environment today on the show
we're talking about
well something that's pretty important
to us sustainable living we're here with
claire potter she's the author of this
new book it's called welcome to the
circular economy
and this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast claire ryan and i we're
going to discuss how helping the
environment actually helps the economy
we'll also address some misconceptions
about living sustainably you can check
that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
advertisements
oh claire thank you so much for being
here thanks so much for being here thank
you for having me it's great to be here
great to have you i really enjoyed your
book and we're gonna dive into the book
but as you know this is a listener
driven show
and so we're gonna get right into the
questions our first question today is
from sam on patreon i'm a fan of safety
and sustainability but it seems like the
pandemic created more waste than ever
with all those disposable masks gloves
test kits to-go containers chemical
cleaners and packaging from online
shopping
what impact did this have on our
environment and how we can we move
forward safely with less waste
now claire it's safe to say that yes
that those are many of the downsides we
all have especially initially we had
some upsides i remember driving around
well actually not driving i was walking
around los angeles
during the beginning of the pandemic and
i noticed how
clear it was here
this is notorious for having a the city
is notorious for having a lot of air
pollution a lot of particulates trapped
in the valley
here and so
that was different but yes there has
been a ton of waste i printed out this
article here ironically because
everything we do is ironic
i printed out this article from cbs news
more than 57 million pounds of ppe and
other covid related plastic waste have
polluted the ocean since the pandemic
began and this is from november last
november wow so it's even more now you
know probably 60 70 million pounds
and so that's obviously a big problem so
it's a mixed bag in some ways can we
talk about what the consequences of this
might be
sure so
that's it's scary statistics and that's
the thing about covid is that it it
suddenly brought so much into sharp
focus we suddenly saw
pollution levels dropping globally you
know mountains that could be seen in
places that you can't use the scene
because the smog
but then we also had people that may be
doing like beach cleans and we're doing
street cleans and saying they were
picking up all this new type of plastic
and all of the stuff that we have the
all the ppe
is plastic based so the stuff that we
didn't have in 2019 as a problem we now
have as a problem with the vast amounts
of stuff that's just escaping into our
environment that's right
and it's really interesting when you
think about plastic as a material
because it isn't necessarily a bad
material it has allowed us to be safe
it's how allowed a lot of people to feel
safe
but then once it escapes our systems
which are flawed and i'm sure we're
going to talk about more that's where it
creates the issue for the wider
environment so we are finding stuff at
you know the bottom of the ocean on
beach cleans as well as just around so
we've got entanglements of um of
different species wherever they are
ingestion so they're eating it as well
breaking down into microplastics so we
are sort of still
finding the impact negative impact
that our ability to handle covid is
going to have yeah and i'm wondering you
know the second part of this question
was how do we move forward safely with
less waste because
it makes sense in some scenarios to have
ppe
otherwise you know the you're in greater
danger of catching a virus that's
potentially deadly etc now what we're
learning with new variants and so forth
that are that are less deadly
i see in the uk they're not masking
children i don't know that they'd ever
have and so um here with the school that
my daughter goes to you know she has to
wear a mask every day and so this is
producing a lot of waste how do we move
forward out of this i mean there's an
individual level and then it seems to me
there's like a more societal or
regulation based level as well yeah so a
lot of the stuff that comes around um
circularity comes around the the terms
of reuse so we're trying to eliminate
single use anything and of course with
ppe you do have single-use masks you
have different single-use items yeah
tests are you know by their very nature
single-use you test you go
a big one which have to be incinerated
which is terrible for the environment
exactly so there are some things that
have to remain single-use there are a
lot of things that have sort of come
into our lives around the pandemic that
we can have as reusable so reusable
masks they are so easy to get hold of
and they are very high quality they give
you more protection or sometimes the
same protection as you know a medical
grade mask
so instead of thinking a single use item
you should think about reusable items
and then that expands outwards into the
rest of your life as well yeah you
talked about uh regulation
and it's almost like to solve the
plastic problem because yes there's a
lot of there's a plastic problem with
all the covet stuff but
not to mention all the other you know
the problems that plastic causes with
you know water bottles and everything
else all these different single-use
packaging um i wonder if it will take
regulation to you know basically say hey
you've got to come up with a plastic
that is biodegradable now i know right
now they do have it maybe you can speak
more of this clear i know they have
biodegradable plastics but um the ones
that i've seen it's you have to like
actually bury those properly and if you
don't bury them properly then they're
you know take just as long to decompose
as regular plastic now probably a little
less hurtful on the environment but um
but yeah what where are we at right now
with these decomposable uh i'm sorry
these compostable plastics sure so um
people probably see there's a variety of
different plastics you have your regular
fossil fuel-based plastics that's
anything like pet like uh you know a
soft drink bottle is usually a fossil
fuel-based plastic yeah so that just
doesn't decompose at all it still is
here now so every piece of plastic we've
ever created
since probably the 1950s is still here
unless we've incinerated it so unless we
burnt it
it exists just albeit in a smaller
amount now
burn all the plastic will be fine
well what is interesting is that once
you have a material that is a problem
that's usually what we go to right you
know we either bury it or we burn it
um and circularity is about trying to
keep those important plastics uh
materials rather going and plastic's a
great material
it's awesome it's lightweight
it's in many regards unbreakable yeah
you can transport things long distances
it's a lower carbon footprint to
transport stuff because they're lighter
it's allowed us to have you know
vehicles that much more efficient so the
material itself is amazing you could go
to the hospital and know that the thing
that's being put on your in your arm is
safe and sterile
so it is a wondrous material but the way
we use it is really bad it's
fundamentally wrong because we use it
single use so they are things like
biodegradable plastics or compostable
plastics and you look again you look at
the pack and go that's awesome because
it's going to go away
but as you said unless you put it into
the right sort of situations which is
higher temperatures industrial
composting facilities
it also doesn't go away so there's
studies in the uk of these compostable
bags you can get you know your groceries
in
and uh researchers have buried them in
the garden thinking you know compostable
packaging and then dug them up years
later and put the same shopping in them
and walked around oh wow it hasn't lost
any structural integrity so it's again
it's the systems we need industrial
composting systems that are readily
available to us all and not just in some
locations yeah and to deal with stuff
like that so right there's so much great
advancements but we haven't quite joined
this so close
i am an optimist
sometimes we think we're recycling and
that's good for the environment that may
not necessarily be true i want to dive
deep into that we've got a long
article to go over there but sam thank
you for your question let's move on to
our callers ryan if you have a question
comment or tip for our podcast you can
call us at
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
looks like we have a question here from
kailyn in miami florida how do you
become an aspiring minimalist
who lives with people who don't
understand the value yet
of living simply and clearing clutter
including paper clutter and clothing so
claire really what kalin's saying here
the question was much longer than that
podcast sean attenuated it down a bit
but the essence of the question is how
do we stay motivated and inspire others
to live a sustainable minimalist life
you know it's funny i i think of two
things ryan and i were just in columbus
ohio uh last month and
we were stuck there was ice storm there
when we when we arrived we were doing a
tour stop the love people use things
tour we're out on the road and one of
the tour stops we had was in columbus it
was at like the nicest mall in ohio the
easton mall and
we're walking in there actually i walked
in by myself and this person comes up
and goes hey minimalist what are you
doing in the mall
and i totally felt like a politician who
was caught in a glory hole
i swear i'm not shopping
um
i have something to do here and all of a
sudden i i realized that like well wait
a minute
i am speaking in a mall ryan and i often
speak in malls
where would we rather speak it wouldn't
make sense for us to go to a buddhist
monastery or a place with a bunch of
monks or something
all right guys let's talk about simple
living yeah and so
if
you're with other people it's not about
proselytizing tor toward them and that's
what i love about your book claire yeah
even with me and ryan like i never
jumped up and said hey ryan you need to
become a minimalist that doesn't work
what does work is showing people the
benefits of simplifying or the benefits
of sustainable living although in your
book you do talk about even though
sustainable is in the title in the book
you talk about how uh well you don't
want to sustain a broken system maybe
you could expand on that a bit yeah so
what's interesting about the term
sustainability is it's one that
everybody knows right so you walk down
the street and if you say to somebody
hey can we have a chat about
sustainability they'll go
yes if they say yes or no they'll
understand what you're talking about
yeah
whereas really when we think about the
word sustain it's to carry on something
you know hopefully indefinitely
sustaining something almost forever
but the way that we've built our systems
we can't do that we can't sustain
something that
hasn't worked for a long time
so it was really frustrating to think
you know i kind of need to talk about
sustainability so people can look at the
book and go
i kind of know what it's going to be
talking about but then really early on i
was like yeah i've only i think it's
five times in the book it says
sustainable because i'm like you know
let's try and get a more descriptive
type of language is it about
regeneration is about circularity what
is it
beyond sustainability but yeah it's the
term that everybody knows whether they
love it or hate it yeah
let's talk a bit about the circular
economy i love the distinction that you
make here so
uh we have like a single use economy
which seems to be what we're going
toward let me just buy everything one
click dispose of it immediately as soon
as i'm done
eat off of plastic plates with plastic
cutlery etc etc right and then you have
the sort of recycling version of that
which is a circuitous route to the same
place
and i learned that in your book and i
never thought about it that way you had
some really simple diagrams in there it
was like
of course that's exactly what happens
but then the circular economy is a bit
different
yeah so linear economy as you said
straight to the bin use something you
take out something out of the ground you
make the thing you you know ends up in
the bin at some point maybe seconds
maybe years recycling goes around a
little bit longer use a bit more but
then circularity
is basically how nature works nature
doesn't have waste so
there's no species that creates anything
that needs to be landfilled or
incinerated
another species will benefit from that
um and it goes round and round without
any loss of quality and benefiting
something else along the way yeah
so we're the only species that doesn't
work like that
on the whole planet and you look at it
and you go um that's kind of dumb yes
that's really dumb that we've kind of
built other ways of working thinking
that we're above that
yeah and we've really not
in the book you talk about how nature
doesn't produce waste
but we we produce waste
and
how strange is it that that all of a
sudden we're pre and we're part of
nature so in a weird way the only way
that nature produces waste is when it
produces humans who produce weight
exactly yeah yeah and it's it's a crazy
thought when quite often when i talk to
people and i say you know we need to try
and function more like nature we need to
learn about systems how things are
interconnected where things are
difficult and trying to find a new
system for that very much like
composting for example like industrial
composting yeah
um and people have that exact reaction
they go oh yeah
well we're kind of in nature too and
it's like yeah we're kind of part of the
biosphere yeah yeah we're the dominant
species but we're certainly not the most
clever even though we think we are
um speak for yourself
[Applause]
but it is it's a it's a really crazy
thought to think how far we've come
thinking that we're above all of that
and it's biting us in the bum man i
think we're just we're a creature of
convenience and that's
i think that's where our downfall is i
mean you mentioned the one-click
shopping i mean it's it's convenient
it's you can have it in la you can have
it the same day and then it comes in a
nice big box and inside that box is a
piece of plastic packaging and inside
that plastic packaging are there little
plastic parts um but it's it was brought
right to our front doorstep
it's really overwhelming when i think
about it because where my mind goes it
goes back to that regulation and i am
not a fan of regulation but it's like i
don't know how else we get past it
because yes on an individual level
we can do uh do our part but you know
just speaking to kalin's question here
yeah when you live with people who are
not on that same mindset it can be a
little disheartening like looking at all
the ways that other people produce
um but yeah unfortunately you can't like
hold a gun to someone's head and make
them do the right thing or unless you're
the government
right exactly which brings me back to
regulation
and i think that's the thing is
regulation that's not one of the three
to ten r's in your book
it is okay
is right at the end it kind of it kind
of picks up on that fact is that you
know we are all individual we have
individual choices however
the choices we've been given by industry
are pretty crap
so we're not being given the right
choices to enable us to do good stuff
and to be able to be impactful in
whichever way very very small or very
big so regulations from above are really
important and what really greets me is
when so much responsibility is put on to
the individual
it's like you should use your reusable
cup and you should do this yeah and you
know a lot of people are already doing
that and you kind of think yeah but
all of the stuff that's been given as
choices quite often is really bad so
my small action is is great but what
about all the big corporations yeah that
are not being held to account i really
am just like hoping for and optimistic
that someone's going to come up with a
cheaper version of a compostable plastic
that doesn't have to be buried a certain
way like we've got to be i mean there's
got to be some r d going on
and as soon as it does like it will
change it'll change the whole game the
other thing to worry about too and you
know this might be going like way too
far off on a tangent but you're but if
you get rid of plastic now you're
messing with oil
and there's a lot of money in oil a lot
of lobbyists who you know lobby to keep
plastic going and oil going so there's
there's just uh there's no simple fix
but i do have hope that there's
something out there yeah i mean that is
a great demonstration of how everything
is linked together
so yeah plastics were originally created
as a waste product to the fossil fuel
industry
so of course when it comes to lobbying
against anti-plastic laws or reduction
or even reusables and reusables can also
be made in plastic and coca-cola's just
announced that they're gonna be creating
more reusable plastic containers for
their products so reuse is still plastic
but when it comes to lobbying
plastics and oil you know their best
buds yeah so you know you're never going
to get progressive change when you have
something that is such a huge industry
that's so encouraging to hear that
coca-cola has done that because that's
you know if we don't regulate it that's
the way that we're really going to
change it because when these big
corporations step up and they're like
they see the problem that they're
causing and then they decide to do
something about it um as long as it's
scaled and it's not just one tiny little
thing where they go oh yeah look at this
really cool little green thing we're
doing over here
everything else in the background yes
which happens a lot yeah but i'm an
optimist yeah me too people embrace it
then hopefully it will grow yeah i mean
i would yeah i'll just leave it at that
i'm an optimist i really want to be like
the corporations are going to do the
right thing but
tweet that podcast
hey caitlin i'm sorry we missed you
while we were on the road since i told
that story about our columbus event i'd
love to send you a recording of that uh
we saw four more events to go because
they all four got postponed so we did 20
cities on this love people use things
tour with our most recent book it's been
a blast it's been our best tour tenth
tour in 12 years you can find all of the
recordings of previous events over at
the minimalist.com
previous or uh caitlin i'll go ahead and
send you the columbus event as soon as
it comes out that one was great we had
denae barahona there
she was awesome uh tk coleman surprised
us and showed up all right it was
amazing
such a such a great event there in
columbus we've had so many good guests
we yeah seth godin um we we had uh matt
nathanson as a guy i mean we've had
there's a lot of awesome live events
there over on patreon yes indeed so you
can find those themminimalists.com
previous all of our past events and even
the previous tours a lot of those we
have filmed or the audio recorded as
well you can just click on a link to
check out the audio over there if you
like laughter you'll love the jp series
episode
with us in atlanta it was it was great
he was 2017. yeah he yeah he basically
uh told me that i dressed like a
homeless man
and other antics yeah and other insults
by jp
we got four more uh tour stops coming up
chicago minneapolis
toronto vancouver you can find all the
information on our website the
minimalists.com
tour do you have any questions from the
live stream alabama we do we have a
question from mike
being vegan is seen to be sustainable
and environmentally friendly but doesn't
growing crops and harvesting fields do
as much damage as farming meat
this is a fascinating question claire
because i think quite often what we get
into here is
we we like to pick a side right and it
becomes
my side and my side's dog well before we
started recording the the patreon live
stream can actually see us ryan was
talking about um but you can go vegan
and eat whole foods or you can go vegan
like ryan did once upon a time and eat
oreos double stuffed oreos eat whole
oreos
and i'm lobbying for a triple stuffed
oreo
i'm sure that'll be one by the end of
the year
single wrapped in plastic right exactly
now claire what what i think we can talk
about here is quite often the things
that contribute to
meat being bad for the environment often
has to do with factory farming it has to
do with non-regenerative
agriculture it has to do with moving
crops from elsewhere in the world in
order to feed animals here in the united
states and so
at terrible factory farms that mistreat
animals and then it also has to do with
you know if you're just eating vegan but
you're eating a bunch of pesticide-laden
plants or a bunch of oreos like that's
also not the ideal yeah and so it's not
necessarily about this binary of here's
good here's bad
it's about understanding all of these
confounding factors that that make
certain well especially ruminant animals
because of the methane that they produce
but all everything else that goes into
it can be can be a tremendous tax on the
environment right yeah definitely and i
think this is i mean we're um we've just
had veganuary which gets bigger bigger
every year so this is when people pledge
to become vegan for the month of january
and this is now a global thing and you
know signatures from all over really
interesting
and i think when people
look at something like veganism and
think you know oh you know is that
actually going to save the planet
because you hear a lot of reports that
say it it will
it's really important to look at the
metrics and not be binary on it so yeah
people go well you're either vegan or
meaty so well no there's
lots of things in between you know you
can choose to
be vegan some of the time and actually
people go oh i can never eat vegan foods
and then you go okay you had a salad
yeah but that doesn't count and you go
well yeah that's exactly that that is
that's exactly the point is eating
plants um but there's some there are
some interest interesting statistics so
um soy is one thing that often people
sort of jump on and say well story
production is responsible for a huge
amount of deforestation some of it legal
some of it illegal
um but most of that story production
actually goes to animal feed
so about 90 percent of some of the sort
of the south american country's
production of soy goes to feed animals
interesting so it doesn't go to feed the
vegans now of course some of it does um
but it's a really really complex system
yes and that is part of it is it's not
just yes or no or black and white or
vegan or carnivore there's all the
different intermeshings of it yeah um
and really we should be encouraging
everybody to just understand a little
bit more about the systems they're in
yeah because i think that's the main
thing because i eat meat every day i
can't eat most plants have a really
terrible autoimmune disease so anytime i
eat fiber full body inflammation
and yet you can eat meat in a way that
comes from regenerative farms it's not
factory farm they're not feeding soy or
corn or all of these other industrial
crops they're actually eating grass
and there's humane slaughter etc and so
when you when you do that that's one way
of being more intentional with your
dietary choices we actually had uh rich
roll my favorite vegan he was on the pod
he's been on the podcast four or five
times at this point now but we had him
on here with paul saladino who's the
carnivore doctor and so we have
rich roll
and paul saladina you would think they
would have nothing in common but they
what we actually talked to them about
was oh no they what they have in common
is making intentional choices avoiding
factory farming avoiding pesticides
avoiding refined seed oils avoiding
oreos and other processed foods right
and they agree on so much of what not to
do
and quite often what you don't do when
you talk about this a bit in your book
has more impact than what you actually
do do yeah yeah 100 and understanding
what's in your food
i mean you can eat whole foods whatever
that's whether that's meat whether
that's fish whether that's dairy veg you
know it's a whole food it hasn't been
sort of tampered with or processed in
any way or you can eat the processed
foods right and some processed food has
got you know a variety of different
health metrics which are good or bad but
a lot of it contains utter rubbish so
regardless of whether you're vegan or
whether you're kind of or whatever it's
understanding what you're putting into
your body because that's the nourishment
we that's the fuel right that's what
we've got to move ourselves on a daily
basis yeah and each of us function
differently so i haven't eaten meat for
oh 14 or 15 years wow my body works
really well on it i did go back to
eating meat for a bit
and didn't do so well and yet yourself
you're the complete opposite yeah and
it's about that balance of understanding
that what suits one person is not going
to suit the next yeah and that's exactly
the same as secularity there's no
template saying everybody has to do this
thing right because it depends where
you're around the world depends on your
culture depends on your economics as
well yeah a lot of people can't afford
to eat
really really healthy foods
because trash food is available
and it's really cheap yeah so how do we
get
the ability and the choices to those
kinds of people to even try and make
better choices it's really really hard
yeah so the key is is being informed
with the diet that you choose what works
best for you where is that food coming
from but so you know to maybe reframe
the question it's not about well is
vegan farming just as harmful maybe it's
um it's factory farming is that harmful
and and that is maybe something that
carnivores and vegans can agree upon
that yeah factory farming can be
detrimental yeah a lot of soy a lot of
corn all this stuff that we're either
feeding the humans or feeding to animals
plus the pesticides they're all over
these things yeah talk about being
the opposite of nourishing your body
we're often poisoning our body with
food-like substances yeah it's not real
food so i love what we're saying here
we're talking about eating whole food
and if you can if you can eat more
plants in your diet then that's one way
to do it or if you can be more
responsible with whatever you're
consuming then that's another way to do
it
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
now claire
this is where we answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response
podcast sean puts them in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you like and
now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place thanks to our good
friend jessica lynn williams
minimalmaxims.com
by the way i should say podcast shine if
you could put in the show notes that
episode we did with
paul saladino and rich roll i just found
that because there was a lot more
agreeing going on there was a bit of a
spat at the end of it but
there was much more agreeing 80 90
agreeing going on
than just simply a debate or an argument
that goes nowhere if we could just like
use that as a model for everything
that's happening in the world right now
we all agree on about 90 percent of
everything but i want to yell at you for
the other 10 right exactly yeah yeah you
could have a better yelling yeah and
that that doesn't ever convert anyone no
the guy who's on the uh corner with the
megaphone yelling at people they're
going to burn in hell they got to call
me out like that
he just does that because he doesn't
like their sneakers though
[Laughter]
we've got a question here from lisa
how can we frame sustainable living in a
way that gets non-environmentalists
interested so here i've got a pithy
answer for you and i think we already
kind of talked about how the benefits
are more beneficial than the what
so here's my here's my pithy answer
living with less is the best way to live
with more
now if you can show that to other people
when ryan came to me and he said hey man
why the hell are you so happy it wasn't
about hey man can you show me how to
declutter my kitchen
my cabinets are too full no no no like
we all know how to declutter our kitchen
the reason we don't do it is we don't
understand the benefits so you can show
it because living with less
is one way for you to live with more
amen yeah yeah
ryan you're gonna think pithy for us all
right i'll go might be the answer i
totally stole from you i'm sure you said
this at some point uh coercion is not
consent
so you cannot coerce someone into being
a an advocate for the environment
there's no
this is the trillion dollar question
right how do you get people who aren't
environmentalists that care about the
environment that is something that
certainly we can't answer 140 characters
but what i can say
is saying the right thing to someone
that's that's that's coercing them and
that's not um that's not how you're
gonna get someone to buy into doing good
things for the environment i will say
like i've seen some ideas on finding
common ground with people so
uh instead of talking about the doom and
gloom of styrofoam and the ozone layer
and you know how we're killing the
planet you can appeal to like hey you
like you like to fish right and you like
to hunt right and if you want to keep
these rivers clean if you want to keep
these forests here so you can keep
hunting you know we've got to look at
some conservation type things so it's
really about finding that common ground
i think is where you can maybe help
people start to see the benefits but
there's nothing you can just like pitch
to them and they're going to be like oh
wow now i'm going to recycle which is a
whole other debate by the way
whether that actually helps or not we're
going to get into that on the on the
maximal uh but with respect to this
question quite often we are so
um want to convince i i need to convince
you i need to convert you to my
singularly
correct worldview
and that kind of self-righteousness will
often make us miserable now i don't know
lisa if uh if that's what you're trying
to do you're just gonna make yourself
really really miserable but if you can
display
what you're doing in a way that shows
the benefits then it might inspire some
other people without having to convince
them at all
yeah i think
not leading by example because that kind
of puts the sort of the thought that
you're in front of somebody else but
just walking alongside somebody and
having a conversation yeah is so
important and you know i quite often say
to people i mean we were talking about
before we started
we're all kind of on the same rock yeah
we're all on earth so really when we
think about you know environmentalism
sustainability we should all have some
level of
you know integration with that or
concerned about that because it's our
home
and whether you have children or not you
know
this is
a responsibility that we have so yeah i
think conversations walk alongside
somebody
have a chat
yeah talk less listen more yeah yeah see
what their point of view is and go from
there yeah and then
the the nice thing that as soon as they
see the benefits it really opens up the
door for that conversation when ryan
came to me and said why the hell are you
so happy it was now the door was open i
can't say well there's this thing called
minimalism i've been trying out yeah you
didn't coerce me you didn't say like a
magic sentence or a magic insult that
made me be like oh i need to minimize
yeah i didn't even convince you you were
convinced without my trying to convince
you yeah and i think that is really the
key we got so much more to talk about
but first alabama what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hey joshua and ryan this is lewis from
rural in the uk
i have a tip related to your 229th
podcast tech problems
the majority of us when we receive a
smartphone never changed the default
sounds played for notifications received
so when we hear one of these default
sounds this can create an unnecessary
urge for us to pull out our smartphones
and only to find the notification was
received on another nearby device
by changing the default sounds on your
smartphone to sounds you don't hear
within your home and working environment
over time you learn to disassociate
these sounds with your smartphone
i have found this helps maintain my
focus in busy environments and has
reduced unnecessary checking of my own
smartphone
hey josh and ryan this is hayley from
arkansas
i feel like i've noticed a lot of other
parents that are trying to get into this
minimalism thing
having trouble knowing what to do with
all of the
crafts and drawings and things that
their children bring home from school
and i recently discovered an app called
keepy
that's k-e-e-p-y
and
it's really neat you can
take a picture of whatever the item is
and you can write a description of it
you can
put when it was created and where
and then you can also
record a video of your child
describing what the drawing is of
and um
you can separate it to all of your
children so you have a different
folder for each child and then you can
share
all these things privately with whatever
family and friends that you
want to
the app costs about 15 a year but that
seems really reasonable to me
to
cut down on the stuff that you're saving
and then there's another app
or um website
called keepsake and that's filled with a
q
so it's q-u-e-e-p-s-a-k-e
and it's a service to help with
recording
memories of your kids kind of in a place
of a baby book if you wanted
and
you can go in and enter your child's
information and then they will text you
questions as frequently as you want to
pay for the free services once a week
but you can have it every day for each
child if you want to and also text
pictures if you want to
so they text you a question and you
reply back and then they save it and
then you can just log in and look at
your book if you want you can print it
out if you desire to at some point
but that's another way that parents can
cut down on some of the clutter
that comes with
um the fun parts of parenting
all right y'all big thanks to our new
friend clara potter check out her book
it's called welcome to the secular
economy the subtitle here is the next
step in
sustainable living we'll put a link to
that in the show notes you can also
follow her on twitter and instagram
she's
at claire potter on twitter we'll put
her instagram in
the show notes ryan real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
you know the pandemic disrupted a lot of
things but one thing it disrupted for us
is we used to go out one of the ways
that you and i make a living
is we speak at places yeah
the minimalists have spoken at harvard
and google and apple and countless other
colleges and companies and conferences
and
when the pandemic happened everyone
started working at home and we didn't
really go out and speak at these places
for a couple years we're finally getting
back to it so if you're interested in
having the minimalist speak at your
organization you can contact our agent
you all the details are over at the
minimalists.com slash speaking the
minimalists.com speaking if you want us
to speak at your event or organization
we'd be happy to consider it we only do
about one or two a month so we can't say
yes to all of them but of course if you
have something that looks appealing
looks like it aligns with what we're
doing we'd be happy to consider it for
added value this week ryan have you
heard of this band called the national
parks i have not i thought the the name
of the
album since we're talking about
sustainable living
quite often we think of um well sort of
apocalyptic or post-apocalyptic
worlds that
living in a non-sustainable way an
unsustainable way leads us to the the
title of their new album is called a mix
for the end of the world part one why
are we so obsessed with the end of the
world man i mean part of it is biblical
i think it goes back to that but you
know what it probably goes back way
before that we're we're obsessed with
the end of things
our life and we want to assume something
goes beyond this we want things to
stretch on in perpetuity as well
anyway it's a great album and it kind of
reminds me of like
just like sitting
or laying down on top of your car and
just looking up at the stars it's that
kind of acoustic singer songwriter but
then there are upbeat tracks as well the
song we're going to listen to at the end
of this episode if you're listening to
the audio version
is headlights or jordan if they can
click up here somewhere i'm sure there's
a youtube version of headlights this is
from the national parks their new album
is called a mix for the end of the world
part one check out headlights by the way
ryan we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what are three
things that every minimalist must
consider to create a more sustainable
life how can our home's interior design
save the planet why is it a bad idea to
recycle plastic plus a million more
questions for claire potter and the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalists to subscribe and get
your personal link so that our weekly
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tick-tock instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalist
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jests
danny unknown emma the immigrant and the
rest of our team i'm joshua fields
milburn reminding you to
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time i guess i should say use fewer
things
for this episode
all right y'all
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it